like the new facial hair click like
below when a guy has a nice shaped head
like this he probably has a nice shape
in big head why is it that girls will
date a guy that has half my wallet half
my dick half my car I still a lot but
those girls that meet they're afraid to
be with me if you look at all the
richest men in the world which I'm one
of I have 20 million in the bank no
google it suck them up
contesting the Kroll show that genies
summoned from a bottle of Axe body spray
is hard rock Nick he's easily the
world's most confident man under six
feet tall who wears jorts
barely a month ago he was quietly being
racist and sexist on the internet like
every other white dude when someone from
irony Twitter posted screen grabs of his
Instagram they got retweeted by some
verified x' and now he's got Klout is
there any way to speed up climate change
and end this nightmare
hard rock Nick is a quote bad boy with
money who likes yummy food barely legal
and all things luxury close quote
I've never seen someone flex so hard on
the gram whether he's bragging about his
12 totally real Mercedes or the mansion
he wants you to believe he lives in it's
no wonder a star was born except his
exes didn't hang themselves in the
garage they got brain cancer lethal
injections or turned gay I'm telling you
you gotta follow this maniac he also
claims he's worth 350 million dollars
and has an 11-inch penis which I know is
BS because there can't possibly be two
of us out there next angle is besides
the ones in his facial hair that's why I
invited into Colver City birthplace of
the no flex zone in this week's
ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
don't Jam the shredder 10 pages max
rocky Nick you have come to the right
place anyone dealing with a major
scandal comes to me and he fixes it what
a Daniel Radcliffe thing exactly
it weren't for me Harry Potter's still
be on death row come here son here's
your new phone there's no camera so you
can't post dick pics to the gram and we
don't provide a charger paddy give me my
file on hard rock Nick hard rock Nick
are you white yes wait yes yes I am
but you aren't media I don't know where
that's coming from I know where it's
coming from you live in Los Angeles and
you look Armenian yeah I'm told you
didn't set out to be like an influencer
on Instagram somebody found you and then
chrissy teigen reposted yes so she
shared it and then another celebrity or
two like Busy Philipps retweeted and
then it gets into the hands of Tom
Segura who has his own podcast if I was
a fraud where's my GoFundMe page like
all that y'all have and look at those
chains though lots of change you're like
does he have no those are beautiful
chains if Tom likes you I like you yeah
do you regret this pose no you can't
start with non-caucasian number one it
just comes off as racist I know what how
is it racist to know what you like
you're sexually attracted in on white
people ah not the way I am white women
no don't worry about that that's no
one's gun as Fame changed you not at all
for so I've always been hated on you
don't come across as a complete asshole
in person see that's the irony I'm an
asshole until you meet me right just cuz
I probably you know have a little bit of
a globe get a little star-struck you see
a man with that shaved on his face
you're gonna respect him the signature
beard yeah just tell me about it I think
it just started wanting to not have the
same beard as every other guy what
instrument are you using is it a wall
yeah yeah it's wall
whoa yeah that's a good clipper you said
this man free Clippers yes
$25,000 let's turn with the eyebrows
everybody focuses on the beer yes and
you completely forget the insane eyebrow
look when you have nothing on top you
better have you know something in front
right what's a typical day for you like
wake up my chef will make breakfast you
mind if I slam on the brakes right here
he's doing oh yeah yeah people fixate on
that a lot he doesn't live with me okay
it's not Wolfgang Puck he comes three
days a week and he makes enough food so
that I'm covered I'm a millionaire 75
times over I'm worth 350 million talk
about your wealth according to your bio
you own a casino in Vegas true or false
true Oh
at the risk of it getting boycotted Ben
Craig called let's keep it at that
burgum Oh 22 with my name
inscribed can we get that Nick Jay
that's sick talk to me about Cologne I
wear a lot of Cologne you wear a lot at
one time or you own a lot of different
both I probably I probably put too much
on today for no reason but wouldn't say
no reason it's working my friend thank
you you've had 12 Mercedes yeah now the
videos I'd watch you're driving a pickup
truck yeah and that's just one of my
former cars yeah was a show truck why do
you have so many stickers in the back
your truck just to make it look a little
modified and customized modified I know
it looks a little trashy it doesn't look
like a man that has a casino hideout in
business his own Netflix and is
excellent at tennis was I said was I
never said I am now you break it here's
something blew my mind such a trump
supporter are you still are you falling
off the wagon along
he has been an enormous president for
our country how much did you give to
Trump because according to my research
I've got 500k from you that's about
right that's a buy might have I might
have exaggerated a little you flexed a
little for the reflects the little for
the gram yeah but it was close I don't
know about any three feet day I got a
big dick no I want to talk about your
huge
eleven inches that's what you're
claiming I'm claiming that's rock hard
that would be full current measuring
from the base of the balls well set
is she a girthy hog it's a good
proportion why do I wear pink I wear
pink because I like pink
you know like inside what are your
thoughts on the me to era it feels a
little bit like an agenda okay I'm gonna
stop you right there I'm gonna revamp
your image just push it up okay yes I
gotta be a vagina knock it off we had a
good run from I get it when men were
created yeah tonight last week
I am told that you've everyone in the
porn business that I wanted to any dudes
no absolutely not I'm a hundred percent
straight but you do accept gay oh
absolutely
sure absolutely for the love of God I
live in West Hollywood have you been
married before
I have how'd that work out it was a
learning experience I actually watched
some footage of you in the courthouse
being disrespectful to the sanctity of
marriage so much so that I am shocked
that that marriage lasted as long as it
did yeah I mean that we were having fun
hard rock Nick we need to clean up your
image you put this on and stick to the
script
if I can keep Paula Deen's racist face
on a tub of butter I can fix whatever
you've said okay Patti you know the
drill good afternoon my social media
accounts were hacked as a straight white
sis mail I am prone to mistakes it's
very possible I was having a reaction to
the eyeliner I use so at this time my
family and I asked for privacy as we
attempt to regain normalcy in our day to
day lives thank you on behalf of flaccid
rock Nick I will be taking questions
from Caucasian reporters only I still
think hard rock Nick might be Armenian
you